hablamos sobre la diseminación de la
información como una fuerza de
convergencia a escala global pero qué
hay de la escala individual y no es que
hablemos de la diseminación a nivel
individual sino que hablamos de la
educación a cierto nivel nuevamente este
es un tema cercano a mi corazón hagamos
algunos experimentos mentales aquí en
general tenemos un ingreso y para poder
ganarse dicho ingreso necesitamos
capital
y también necesitaremos mano de obra
por ejemplo si tenemos una granja
necesitaremos tierra animales y equipo
pero también necesitaremos a personas
que manejen el equipo y administren la
granja
si tenemos una compañía de software
vamos a necesitar un edificio se
necesitarán servidores y computadoras
pero también necesitaremos personas para
programar las computadoras y para vender
el software también para el desarrollo
etcétera estas son las cosas que
necesitamos para producir una salida la
cual reconoceremos en términos del
ingreso pero la cuestión es cómo vamos a
repartir el ingreso cuánto va a ir al
capital y cuánto va a ir a la mano de
obra la idea aquí es que al tener esta
diseminación del conocimiento en el
trabajo especializado se va a volver más
valioso cada vez vamos a dibujar un aura
alrededor de esto que es el aura del
conocimiento es una mano de obra
especializada con conocimiento el cual
es cada vez menos un producto por
aquí la mano de obra tiene un mayor
apalancamiento por otra parte tenemos
estas enormes industrias tremendamente
capitalizadas en donde la mano de obra
hacía un trabajo monótono y poco
especializado entonces aquí el capital
quizá tenga mayor apalancamiento
y tiende a no considerar esto lo
suficiente en una gran escala él dice
que podría estar ocurriendo esto solo en
lugares muy particulares como en las
finanzas o la administración o en
ciertas industrias como la del software
pero el autor opina que esta
diseminación del conocimiento no va a
hacer que la mano de obra sea lo
suficientemente importante como para
equilibrar que vaya al capital una mayor
parte del ingreso especialmente después
de que pasen las generaciones que
potencialmente lleven el capital a
riquezas dinásticas y con los
experimentos mentales que les propongo
aquí no son para dar mi opinión o puntos
de vista sino para darles ideas sobre
las cuales ustedes puedan reflexionar de
manera que encuentren sus propios puntos
de vista aquí vamos a comparar la época
actual con la era dorada que es lo que
hace el libro si observamos la era
dorada o la era de oro al final del
siglo 19 cuáles serán las fuerzas de
crecimiento en ese entonces
de donde se generaba el ingreso pues
estábamos en la cima de la revolución
industrial teníamos 3 petróleo o energía
teníamos menos factura
todas estas industrias son intensamente
capitalistas el capital es muy
importante de hecho no se puede hacer
ninguna de estas cosas si no se tiene
capital y toda la mano de obra aquí se
volvió algo así como un producto si
necesitas personas para clavar las guías
del tren o cosas por el estilo como
gente para trabajar en una línea de
ensamblaje la revolución industrial fue
un proceso que tomó todos estos oficios
y los convirtió en mano de obra tipo
producto ahora pensemos en la época
actual a la que podemos referirnos como
la era de la información y una de las
industrias de crecimiento en la era de
la información que tengo cerca del
corazón también ya que estoy grabando
este vídeo usando software software y
también otra industria en crecimiento es
la biotecnología biotecnología
y podríamos enumerar muchas más
industrias que tienen en común estas
industrias pues no requieren tanto
capital como estas otras si hablamos del
software no se va a requerir demasiado
capital solo se necesita un lugar para
las computadoras que puede ser la casa
de alguien y las computadoras pero lo
importante aquí son las personas con el
conocimiento altamente especializado que
será nuestra mano de obra lo mismo
sucede con la biotecnología aunque aquí
sí se necesita capital pero no la
cantidad de capital necesario como para
la construcción de trenes se va a
requerir equipo pero principalmente para
las personas para los investigadores que
realizan las pruebas clínicas y todo lo
demás así que pareciera que estamos en
una era en la que la mano de obra se
vuelve cada vez más valiosa pero no la
mano de obra tipo producto que trabaja
un turno en la fábrica sino una mano de
obra altamente especializada debido a
que esto está sucediendo
ser un conductor para que una mayor
parte del ingreso vaya a la mano de obra
pero esto no es algo que por sí solo
necesariamente elimine la desigualdad
por ejemplo podemos tener una situación
y algunas personas opinan que esto sí
está sucediendo en donde vemos que aquí
tenemos un grupo de personas de las
cuales aquellas personas que pueden
participar aquí en estos sectores de
gran crecimiento en donde la mano de
obra tiene un valor significativo sólo
una fracción pequeña de esta población
así que sólo esta pequeña fracción de la
población podrá tomar ventaja de estas
dinámicas el resto de la población que
no tiene estas habilidades o
conocimientos pues quedarán fuera de
este crecimiento lo cual puede seguir
llevando a la desigualdad no es el tipo
de desigualdad en la cual mucho del
ingreso va al capital debido a que eres
mayor que se o que el rendimiento de
capital es mayor que el crecimiento
sino que la desigualdad se ocasionará
por esta diferencia en la mano de obra
mano de obra altamente especializada
obtiene una participación
desproporcionada en comparación con los
otros tipos de mano de obra así que la
cuestión es podemos hacer que más
personas participen de esto nuevamente
este es un problema de educación podemos
tomar este grupo como porcentaje de la
población para que se vuelva más grande
y así una mayor parte del mundo pueda
participar en esto esto es algo para
reflexionar
yo no tengo las respuestas sin embargo
hay diferentes dinámicas que están
ocurriendo y que nos ponen en un mundo
diferente del que existía en la era
dorada otra forma de ver esto no es algo
del libro sino la forma en que yo lo veo
si pensamos en la revolución industrial
el mundo era como una pirámide en donde
la mano de obra se encuentra la mano de
obra
se encuentra en la base de la pirámide
muchas personas aquí pero poco
especializadas en el medio tenemos los
trabajos digamos que ejecutivos o de
oficina aquellas personas que manejan la
información archiva los documentos
etcétera y en la punta de la pirámide
durante la revolución industrial y hasta
el siglo 20 tenemos a los dueños del
capital
y una pequeña clase creativa personas
como los ingenieros artistas e
investigadores esto es lo que teníamos
en ese entonces ahora en la era de la
información la automatización hace que
la mano de obra sea menos importante e
incluso los trabajos ejecutivos o de
oficina por lo que aquí tenemos dos
realidades diferentes de este lado
tenemos un grupo relativamente pequeño
que es dueño del capital o que son una
clase creativa y debido a que la
automatización se está haciendo cargo de
esto de en medio tenemos esta pequeña
fracción de personas que siguen
participando acá por lo que todo lo
demás quedará afuera afuera lo cual no
es bueno para nadie pero hay otra
realidad qué tal si pudiéramos expandir
este pequeño triángulo para tener una
mayor clase creativa que participe en la
mano de obra altamente especializada de
manera que estén en posición de tener
una mayor participación en el ingreso
a su vez les facilitará tener una mayor
participación en el capital pueden ver
que esto está sucediendo en sillicon
valley donde las personas obtienen
buenos trabajos en google o en facebook
o en apple y obtienen esto mediante su
mano de obra pero debido a que su
ingreso es mayor que sus gastos han
podido comenzar a acumular capital y
eventualmente se vuelven dueños del
capital así pues hay una realidad en la
que si jugamos bien nuestras cartas de
educación algo que vuelvo a mencionar es
muy cercano a mi corazón quizá en lugar
de tomar este papel en donde dejamos
fuera a todas estas personas podemos
llegar a un mundo que luce así donde no
necesitamos mucha mano de obra debido a
la automatización como mano de obra tipo
producto
y tampoco necesitamos tanto trabajo de
oficina o ejecutivo en el proceso de
información y donde la mayoría de las
personas si logramos que la educación
sea lo suficientemente buena podrán
participar de estos trabajos mejor
valorados en donde la mano de obra tiene
un mayor apalancamiento y el rendimiento
de esta mano de obra es mayor que el
rendimiento del capital por lo que estas
personas tendrán una mayor participación
en el ingreso y podrán comenzar a
acumular capital van a llegar a esta
realidad en donde la mayor parte de las
personas son dueños del capital
ingenieros de software artistas y
personas realizando investigación y
desarrollo pues en mi mente esto sólo se
puede hacer mejorando la educación
necesitaremos un mayor grupo de mano de
obra talentosa y mejor educada con mayor
conocimiento de lograr esto podremos
llegar a una realidad tipo viaje a las
estrellas o star trek en donde no se ven
muchas personas a dando los campos o
haciendo trabajo de escritorio ya que
todo se de star trek
haciendo investigación o explorando
y haciendo arte nuevamente esto es algo
para reflexionar la diseminación del
conocimiento y la educación son fuerzas
muy poderosas de convergencia y ayudarán
a evitar que entremos a otra era dorada